with JavaScript array variables we can
store several pieces of data in one
place you can start an array declaration
with an open square bracket and end it
with s closing square bracket and then
you put a comma between each entry so
you start in a rate declaration with an
open square bracket and you end it with
a closed square bracket and then you put
a comma between each entry so these are
all strings but you can also store
numbers you can store objects you can
store boolean's and any data type you
can store in an array you can also nest
arrays within other arrays so one of the
things you can store in an array is
another array these are called
multi-dimensional arrays here's an
example of that so inside this first
array there's two other arrays so this
is the first item in the first array
which is an array and it's the second
item in the array which is another array
and inside this race there are two items
there's a string and a number an array
can have multiple different types of
data types in the array you can access
elements of arrays using indexes if I
use these brackets after the name of the
array and I put the index of the element
in the array now indexes start at 0 so
peanutbutter is 0 jelly is 1 and bread
is 2 let's run that and we can see jelly
in the console here you can also change
array elements using indexes ok I
actually like peanut butter and banana
sandwiches better than peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches so I have access array
index 1 which is gently and I set that
equal to bananas and then you can see I
lock the sandwich array and over on the
console we have peanut butter bananas
and bread you can also access elements
of multi-dimensional arrays with indexes
you can change the elements to let me
show you how you do that
so you have to use two set of sets of
brackets the first set of brackets
refers to the entry in the outermost or
the first level of the array and each
additional pair of brackets refers to
the next level of entries inside so NX 1
is going to be here this is 0 right here
and this is 1 and then the next index is
index 0 so within this array right here
we have index 0 index 1 so that's going
to cancel that log White Sox and there
we go at the end White Sox you can also
change the elements just like that
so if I take the same thing here I'm
going to put Red Sox and then we're
going to cancel that log teams and you
can see the array is now both 23 Red Sox
45 instead of the White Sox one of the
methods that all arrays have is for each
let me show you how that works so here
is the array with a for each method on
it so we have sandwich that for each
that means for each element in the
sandwich array we're going to do
something and you have to pass in a
function to show what you're going to do
with each element so in the function
whatever you put inside these
parentheses here R is that each element
of the array so we're going to pass it
each element of the array into this
function and we're going to console that
log2 element so we're just going to
print each item in the array so if I run
that C at the end you can see if each
line there's peanut butter bananas bread
now you can do a lot more complicated
things this allows you to just do
something with each element of an array
check out my common array methods video
to learn more about array methods well
that's the basics of arrays thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good